c'est un succès appelée festival pour la
culture sur les résultats de ce concert
pilotes sont très claires l'événement
n'a pas eu d'impact sur la transmission
de lakovic 19 entre les participants le
27 mars dernier près de 5000 personnes
avaient assisté à un concert à barcelone
dans la plus grande salle de la ville et
sans distance sociale cette expérience
est le fruit d'une collaboration entre
les festivals musicaux des
professionnels de la santé et des
institutions
il avait mis en place un strict
protocole les participants devaient
avoir entre 18 et 65 ans il devait
porter un masque ffp2 et une prise de
température était effectué à l'entrée à
l'intérieur la piste est divisé en
plusieurs parties et un système
permettait de contrôler la qualité de
l'air le jour même les spectateurs
devaient obligatoirement effectuer un
test antigénique dans l'un des lieux
habilité pour l'événement et un mois
après on sait donc que sur les 5000
personnes seules six personnes ont été
positives dans les 14 jours après ce
concert dont 4 n'ont pas été contaminés
pendant l'événement alors tous et est
asymptomatique ou présenté de légers
symptômes
les organisateurs se disent très
satisfaits par la route et ma conclusion
la conclusion finale et que selon la
cedh ans à 14 jours des assistants il y
a aucun signe qui suggère qu'il y ait eu
transmission à l'intérieur des
installations du concert globalement
l'analyse des résultats indiquent en
concert live dans un endroit fermé
auquel assistent 5000 personnes qui
chantent et qui dansent qui peuvent se
prendre dans les bois en ayant passé un
test antigénique avant en portant un
masque ffp2 et avec une bonne
ventilation est une activité sur le
secteur assure enfin voir le bout du
tunnel
il espère que cette expérience permettra
d'organiser des événements de grande
envergure et notamment des festivals
musicaux dès cet été à barcelone